um talk to me about the strikes
um schools are struggling to plan for
tomorrow's strikes apparently unions
told members to keep head teachers in
the dark is that irresponsible or smart
tactic look I don't want to see any
strikes happening at all and and when
the they are strike action is happening
I want so much information to be made uh
available as possible what we saw during
the pandemic was kids education must
have been affected by having to not be
in school not be able to learn and not
have that teachers there in front of
them um I don't want to see that strike
action happening now those kids have
already had a really tough time over the
last few years and I think we should
have teachers in the classroom teaching
where possible and I I don't think we
want to make it even more difficult for
head teachers to prepare at the moment
okay so are the tactics smart or are
they irresponsible well I don't think
it's responsible for teachers to be
going out on strike at this moment in
time I think we've seen as I've said a
couple of years it's been really tough
for kids and I've been in a lot of my
own local primary schools across
Northwest Durham over the last few
months where they've said there's been a
real impact of the pandemic on
children's education and I want to see
is returning to normal ensuring those
children can get the education that they
need to get on and succeed in life I
don't think we should see a strike
action as we're seeing at the moment
what's your advice to parents I mean
they're doing their level best to try
and you know
food on the table
I'm gonna do tomorrow when the kids are
not at school no well it's really tough
there are going to be people's lives are
going to be seriously affected by this
we've seen that in other sectors as well
like in transport which we know has also
had knock-on effects on people's lives
their ability to get to work to take the
kids to school and things like that as
well so I really don't want us to see us
in a space where we're seeing so much
strike action you know it comes to
classroom teachers the average teachers
on about 39 and a half thousand a year
and whatever the government's already
offered a five percent settlement which
would take that to well over 40 000 a
year and that's the average classroom
teacher plus around quarter of their
salary as a pension contribution as well
I think it's a reasonable package
overall and look I don't want to see
public sector workers out on strike
because the impact it has on everybody
else and you're right it's not just on
the kids it's not going to impact on
wider families as well and the ability
of their parents to get to work too okay
yesterday we heard how the mod has been
hollowed out by years of underfunding
with chatted a former senior General as
well who told us that money should be
spent on defense rather than potholes
given that it's a subject closer to your
heart do you agree I think what we need
to see is a balance across government if
I'm totally honest I don't think it
should always spent on one or the other
we've got to see that balance we can
only get that balance if we got the
economy growing and that's what I want
to see us focus on that's what I see a
government's first responsibility is to
defend the realm are you absolutely
right and you know we're the biggest
defense spender in Europe uh one of them
one of a handful of countries in NATO
which spends above two percent well we
could say it's not enough for everything
really but it's all about trying to get
that balance within what is a
constrained environment at the moment
the mod defense project shouldn't be
bigger no of course it should but it's
got to be grown but it's got to be grown
in that in that sensible way where we're
still seeing uh two percent of GDP
minimum there and but it's got to be
done in a balanced way with other parts
of the economy like public services
um health education and transport and
all those other things it's all about us
having to see things in the round but do
you acknowledge that defense has to be
the most important the defense is always
the most important thing for any
government to do but I think when you
see the way that you know I was a
special advisor in the ministry of
Defense before I was an MP a few years
ago you know the way that Britain
stepped up when other countries didn't
when it came to Ukraine after the
invasion of Crimea you know as Britain
was the UK training their soldiers it's
the way you've seen it now with um Rishi
and Ben ensuring that we're the ones
there at the Forefront of sending heavy
armor to help the ukrainians I think you
can see Britain leading in Europe and as
a world leader as well in defense but
yeah it's got to be part of a balanced
package but I want to see is a punching
above our weight as we have done over
the last few decades to that end should
we be sending Ukraine fighter jets well
I think we've got to see it in the round
I think what we've done is we've led the
way with training initially now we've
we've led the way with the enlarsio's
anti-tank missiles
well I think we need to that's going to
be that's going to be the decision for
somebody at a slightly higher level than
me with much more knowledge of the
situation no you just told me you worked
in the ministry of Defense I did I did
but I think
I think what we've got to see is that uh
the people of the knowledge of the
situation at the moment need to make
those decisions that's the decision
which was made around tanks as well that
had been not not been an easy decision
not what we made at an earlier stage but
as the situation evolves the situation
changes and we've seen over the last you
know year to 18 months how that
situation has evolved only a few months
ago Germany wouldn't send any form of
um uh Weaponry at all uh to the Ukraine
and the question is we've known the
Dutch the Dutch has said ask us the
Dutch government has said ask us and
we'll look at it favorably the polls
have said ask us and we'll look at it
favorably should we be saying the same I
think we'll we'll all the government
will always look at all options but what
we've got we look at it favorably I'm
sure we'll always look at everything
that president was allowed to ask for
favorably that's why we've been there
the ones pushing on heavy armor that's
why we were some of the ones there at an
earlier stage pushing on those anti-tank
missiles as well and we've been leading
on that I'm sure I've seen as I drive up
to my constituency every week I've seen
the Dutch forces as well there helping
us train those Ukrainian soldiers too
and I think what we've seen actually
over the last uh couple of years is
where Britain's LED others have followed
we've certainly been leading in Europe
on that and I think it's made us you
know it's made all of us concentrate on
what's very important which is the
fundamental rule of law and democracy
and which is what we've been standing up
for okay IMF report I'm sure you're
brief for this one the UK is on course
to be the world's worst performing major
economy I.E the chance that's getting it
wrong well I think if you look into the
MF report I did what they've said also
is that they've praised what the
government have done since uh over the
last few months with Jeremy uh and Rishi
coming in and helping stabilize the
situation well we've been worse could it
I mean the previous prime minister
completely crashed the economy what we
also have seen over the last few months
though is that actually the UK has
outperformed the imf's predictions for
last year and the oecd's predictions and
the year before since 2016 we've you
know performed better than Germany for
example which is Europe's largest
economy so I think actually when you see
it in the round I'm interested in
outcomes what's then this is now and
indeed and they made those same
predictions then and I'm interested in
what our economy is even worse than
Russia well that's what they say
the proof will be in the pudding so what
are you saying I've got it wrong well
that's what they they did in the last
couple of years and and I think Britain
can outperform its predictions like it
has them for the last two years when you
look over the last couple of years we've
outperformed Germany and Japan as well
you know these are these are big world
economies which we've outperformed
relatively I want to see is that I'm not
saying it's going to be an easy time
we've got those huge headwinds around
Energy prices inflation which isn't just
knocking on to you know the fuel at the
pump or onto gas but it's also knocking
onto things like food which we've seen
food price inflation so much higher
we've got that's one of the reasons
we've got to get inflation under control
because it makes everybody poorer
particularly those who can least afford
it you say that they're praising um the
chancellor and the Prime Minister but
when I was reading it it said a tight
they blame the contraction of the
British economy on a tighter fiscal and
monetary policy
that's the chancellor right that's
totally different to what they'd said uh
four months ago when they praised about
the UK government and also look the
governor of the bank of England's also
said uh very clearly uh that he thinks
that the actions that the chancellor
have taken has actually made the
recession uh shallower uh and will mean
that we can bounce back quicker and I
think just to clarify the IMF is wrong
and this government will prove them
wrong about the economy here I think so
and and the IMF has also changed its
changed its mind on some of these
aspects before and the figures have
shown that the AMF were wrong that's why
when we were predicted to be slower
growing than other countries actually
we've been quicker than say Germany and
Japan and I think we can still
outperform over the next few years as
well who do you think will be the um
best chairman of the party oh well I
mean that's well above my pay grade
you've got a view I do I have lots of
views but I think will be most appealing
to the election it's usually best to
keep those views to myself all right I'm
convinced that the Prime Minister will
make a sensible smart one I said Boris
sensible and clear decision on the
future I don't think in Venice this is
something that Boris will want to do
seems to be quite happy doing what he's
doing at the moment we're making quite a
lot of money well indeed okay it's good
to see you thank you much appreciated